foreign
there are many Power Systems in the
world of anime but one constant thing
that's in these Power Systems is the
ability to harness the elements one
element that's been portrayed throughout
the years and across countless anime is
fire whether it's obliterating hundreds
of enemies or dishing out ungodly
amounts of damage to a single one these
fire users know how to look cool while
making their opponents look like Scrubs
without further Ado these are the best
moments when anime fire users flexed on
their opponents let's start with one
piece when Ace destroys Baroque Works
billions Fleet
ha
foreign
crew attempts to escape they found
themselves in a bit of a predicament but
one man jumped in to save Luffy and his
crew from imminent danger it was none
other than Luffy's sworn older brother
fire Fist Ace with his polite and kind
demeanor one wouldn't expect him to be
the type of man who packs enough power
to wipe out an entire fleet what
elevates this moment into flag status
isn't the fact that he defeated the
entire fleet but because he did so while
at Sea in a small raft nonetheless their
biggest ships and Manpower didn't matter
one bit when a single attack
effortlessly destroyed their entire
fleet leaving behind wrecked ships and
one man standing
oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
up next we have the man himself
[Music]
the man who would take on thousands of
Shinobi in the fourth Shinobi War the
entire fight was basically a flex for
this man taking on multiple opponents in
hand-to-hand combat and subsequently
overpowering them when it comes to
Ninjutsu all without much of an effort
at all it's when we first get to witness
Madara using Great Fire of annihilation
when damari uses a Ninjutsu against him
he also retaliates by using a Ninjutsu
of his own a sea of fire that was wide
enough to cover a significant portion of
the opposing side's army with the
Shinobi Army only surviving because of
multiple shinobis combining their
strength just to stop a single attack
from one of the most memorable villains
in Naruto history may God have mercy on
the man who decides to step in his way
[Music]
let's move on to UU Hakusho he is Dragon
of the darkness flame devouring
[Music]
with the Dark Tournament Arc well on its
way he ate and zero Now find themselves
to be the next in line to fight after a
heated exchange of words where they
basically insulted each other the fight
opens up with zeru on the advantage as
he unleashes a barrage of fireballs and
subsequently Powers himself up by
absorbing the heat he emits giving his
body an ethereal reddish glow but with
all that effort it still wouldn't be
enough to take hea out with him taking
out his jargon eye and unleashing the
dragon of the darkness flame zeru is
Frozen in fear as he ate unleashed the
attack with enough force that the whole
Arena felt its intense presence and
power completely disintegrating his
entire being only leaving behind a
shadow of his body in the arena walls he
a stands Victorious albeit wounded
because of the intensity of the attack
without a doubt an Overkill move but
that's what we all came here to see some
good old-fashioned flexing
baby
next up we have a Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Roy Mustang versus lust
[Music]
ER
with episode 19's wild development
Alphonse and Riza found themselves
cornered by lust with Riza reaching her
breaking point and alfons barely holding
off last attacks it seemed like death
was knocking on their doors but one
voice broke through all that chaos with
Roy Mustang entering The Fray the tide
of the battle was turned to their favor
with alfonse's quick thinking making a
wall to protect him and Riza Roy then
unleashes a barrage of Hellfire upon
lust or makes this battle memorable
isn't the fight itself but instead what
transpired before the fight with Roy
intentionally burning his own flesh to
cauterize the wound he previously got
from lust and carving a transmutation
circle on his hand was using Flint as
ignition the battle ended when lust was
overwhelmed by his Flames slowly
crumbling away to nothingness with his
Ingenuity and quick thinking Roy comes
out on top
thank you
whilst making a fire user list you
couldn't miss out the most famous and
iconic fire users out there so Natsu
Dragneel is taking his spot at number
seven
[Music]
on the fourth day of the grand magic
games and on its last fight of the day
Natsu took on two of saber 2's strongest
members despite the pair doing their
best and unleashing a massively powerful
spell all of that is nothing when held
to the fire Mage himself who counted
with a powerful spell rendering theirs
useless and subsequently knocking them
down and out of the competition now one
might not like the whole power of
friendship that fairy tale commonly uses
but you can't deny the absolute Flex
that is fighting two of the most
powerful Dragon Slayers the
saber-toothed Guild has and coming out
on top
[Music]
next on our list of fire users we have
the father of shoko dodoroki the new
number one Pro Hero himself endeavor
[Music]
thank you
what do you do when you encounter an
enemy that adapts to fire if you want to
bring in more fire you might just be
right along the alley of endeavor
himself this moment comes from his
battle with the high-end nomu nicknamed
Hood an enemy that he had a hard time
dealing with because of its unique
regeneration Quirk even with the help of
hawks the number two Pro Hero and with
all of it being watched by civilians in
the city and live on television Endeavor
had no choice but to Chuck that number
into the stratosphere where he can go
all out he then goes beyond his limits
and chance the motto that he's hated for
so long using a maximum power heat rate
to burn away nomu with a plus Ultra
prominence burn the attack resembles a
giant Fireball Illuminating the city
below giving hope to the masses and
striking fear into the hearts of
villains all hail the new number one
hero
delicious
the next Flex comes from Lion sin of
Pride himself the almighty escanor from
the seven deadly sins
you've probably guessed which moment
this is that's why this is escanor's
Introduction in season two of seven
deadly sins it's just such a badass
moment that it almost feels wrong to
leave it out of this list if we're
talking about fire users flexing on
their opponents what's better than
flexing against one enemy flexing
against two enemies of course escanor
hands down one of the most satisfying
beat downs to two of The Ten
Commandments gallant and molescular this
scene not only shows us escanor's power
but also his personality is by the end
of it all he seems bored and
disappointed at how weak the Demon's
attacks were showing why he's called The
Lion sin of pride
oh my God
when talking about fire users in anime
we can't avoid talking about the anime
that's about fire users themselves
fire force has tons of cool characters
but if we had to choose one it's going
to be the captain of the seventh company
Benny Maru shinmon due to him possessing
both second and third generation
abilities Benny model is an expert in
all types of combat and his abilities
allow him to create destructive
long-range projectiles redirect external
heat sources and gunfire amplify his
martial arts another fight and redirect
almost any pyrokinetic attacks this
coupled with his incredible skills makes
Benny Maru one of if not the most
powerful character in all of fire force
he's literally said to be akala himself
which in Buddhist mythology is said to
be a wrathful deity and protector of
righteousness this particular fighter
only shows just how willing he is to
help and protect his people but also
gave us one of the most ungodly sound
effects in recent memory the opponent
wasn't even a pushover as the demon
infernal was shown to dominate the fight
against Shinra and Arthur and even shrug
off the initial blows of the captain it
was only after taking the demon down to
the night skies did Benny Maru
power loose
[Music]
finally we have the most recent anime on
our list bleach thousand year blood wolf
touch the Beloved Shonen anime returns
for its final story arc and gives the
captain commander of the goatee 13 his
much awaited Limelight his fight against
the main villain yuha finally shows us
his Bankai zanka nodachi a sword of
tremendous flame said Flames within the
blade burn anything it cuts out of
existence it also has the ability to
call on the corpses it's burned over the
many years it's so dangerous the red Su
unohana believes that the Flames of
zankar nodachi could incinerate the
entirety of Soul Society if left active
for too long while the uhahi fights is
revealed to be a clone at the very end
it's still important to note how he
managed to make the Imposter look like a
normal grunt against his blades Flames
props a cool boat for making this old
man so badass in his final fight the
visuals of the gigantic Flames Gathering
into the blade were top-notch as is the
devastation caused by the fight in Soul
Society Rest In Pieces Yamamoto
foreign foreign
[Music]
and those are my favorite moments when
fire users flexed on their opponents but
with so many characters that control
flames in anime there's bound to be some
that I've missed right let me know what
you're thinking in the comment section
below I'm glad to have you here and
thank you so much again for watching
this video